The amazing thing about pedigrees is that a pedigree for
any given trait, like lactose intolerance, will allow us to
compare family relatedness with the prevalence of that trait. So
here, we see Kate, and she's affected, because we see
that here circle is filled in. We see her parents
are unaffected, because they're not shaded. Her brother is not
affected because he's not shaded. But, her maternal grandfather is
affected because His square is shaded and her paternal aunt,
her dad's sister is also shaded, also affected.
The shading of these shapes in the pedigree
allows us to identify the phenotype, or the
observable condition or trait of an individual. So
in this pedigree, Kate's phenotype is lactose intolerance.
Whereas, her brother's phenotype is lactose tolerance. So
what other information do you think you could
get from this pedigree here, of Kate's family concerning
the trait of lactose intolerance? Take a look
at each of these particular options and then
look at the pedigree, and determine whether or
not you think it's true. Check any and
all boxes that you think apply. Remember, if
you're affected, you're shaded in. Meaning that you
have lactose intolerance. And, if you're not shaded
in, you're unaffected, meaning you are lactose tolerant.